a community coming together to remember
mason dominguez police say the
four-year-old's body was found in a
freezer inside a home near kerry and
lamb tuesday his mother's boyfriend is
now facing charges connected to his
death sasha loftis was at a vigil to
honor mason tonight and she starts our
team coverage
denise and brian you can see here there
are candles flowers signs balloons right
in front of the house where mason's body
was found yesterday those who knew him
loved him and lived nearby say this is
something they'll never understand
a sound of sadness and overwhelming
grief to remember the life and sudden
death of a child
family friends and neighbors gathered
wednesday to remember mason dominguez
police say the four-year-old's body was
discovered in a freezer in this home's
garage four-year-old victim in this
particular case was found deceased
35-year-old brandon tosland mason's
mother's boyfriend is accused of killing
the child and concealing his body for
two months and officers tell the 8 news
now i-team this investigation is just
beginning there's about 10 weeks of
activity that we're trying to find out
according to court documents mason's
mother said she hadn't seen him since
december and lieutenant ray spencer says
his body had visible injuries the
suspect
is alleged to have been physical with
the victim and had spanked him
excessively and police say this was all
brought to their attention when mason's
sister handed a teacher a note saying
she and her mother were being held
against their will their details many
here say they can hardly comprehend
as those who knew and loved mason honor
who he was
and what they believe he should have
become
investigators tell the 8 news now i-team
that they will not know mason's official
cause of death until an autopsy is
conducted in the next few days now
tozlin we're told is due back in court
to face a judge on monday reporting live
tonight sasha loftis live local now